dernier d'une famille de dix neuf
enfants andré gagnon passe une enfance
heureuse à saint pacôme de kamouraska
dans une famille amatrice de musique
très jeune il montre du talent pour le
piano oui je me souviens que le clavier
la rivière exactement la hauteur du
menton et il va prenais ma soyez sur
bang j'ai bien noté les chants religieux
chante rendaient à l'église
salon qu'il développe ensuite à montréal
au conservatoire de musique et il
accompagne aussi plusieurs chansonniers
du groupe les bozos et cherche un piano
des prochaines et monsieur parce que
c'était une chance pouvoir accompagner
les gens au début des années 60
claude léveillée lui offre de monter sur
scène à ses côtés pour son premier
spectacle au québec c'est le
commencement d'une collaboration de huit
années en concert et sur disque andré
gagnon composera d'ailleurs la musique
d'un grand succès de l'éveillé pour les
amants
[Musique]
mais c'est à paris où il poursuit des
études de piano qu'il se découvre lé
envie de faire du spectacle
j'ai réalisé que le spectacle du
légendaire
c'est beaucoup plus qu'attendu en 1969
andré gagnon met fin à sa carrière
d'accompagnateurs et se lance sur scène
en solo il interprète alors ses propres
compositions qui navigue entre musique
classique et populaire
il enregistre avec des orchestres
symphoniques mais se retrouve aussi à
danser la claque est la seule prétention
au kgb spectacle quant à moi c'est
d'être sur la fin
[Musique]
en 1975 son deuxième disque neige est un
succès international
la pièce wahou et joués dans les
discothèques du monde entier
[Musique]
il connaît de nombreux autres succès
couronné par des félix au québec et des
juno au canada au japon ont l'adorent et
il fait des disques spécialement pour
son auditoire nippon mais andré gagnon
est attaché à la culture québécoise
[Musique]
il fait chanter par monique leyrac les
textes du poète nehlig ans qu'il a mis
en musique
ils composent l'opéra nehlig ans sur un
livret de l'écrivain michel tremblay
[Musique]
ils montrent aussi des spectacles
hommages aux violoneux jean carignan et
à la bonne duc la thur lutteuse
très prolifique il compose de la musique
pour le cinéma mais surtout pour la
télévision
aussi bien dans les émissions pour
enfants que pour les grands jusqu'à la
fin andré gagnon reste discret sur sa
vie privée sal son piano peut raconter
toute sa vie mon meilleur ami
geneviève asselin radio canada montréal
c'est lui qui sait
[Musique]
ce que vous direz ma voix
la halle
si je savais
[Musique]